you guys love reliving the invention of
the Greek and Roman alphabets like it's
some climax in the history of writing
but real language nerds drool over
Korean and here's why another time
another King this time in a Korean
palace he presents himself as King
Sejong as you get a grip on your
surroundings you begin to tell him of
your journeys yet with a sweeping gaze
the king looks right past you you've
been out for a very long time over a
thousand years the world has come so far
and the scripts you once knew have - he
reminds you of the old Chinese
logographs and sound meaning
combinations those are still useful to
his court to a point you see Chinese has
these nice word units one after another
but Korean he boast has these elegantly
complex words with different pieces and
endings fitting Chinese writing to
Korean grammar hasn't been easy he tells
you of a people across the sea who've
gone through a similar struggle the
Japanese simplified Chinese characters
by turning them into a fixed syllabary
which they now use alongside the Chinese
characters so they have these syllable
characters and these thousands of Han
characters they use the Han characters
for the meaning heavy components
vocabulary terms then they use the
syllabary to write little grammatical
words and word pieces or new vocabulary
words that don't historically have their
own Chinese logograph such a complicated
system gentlemen the king has an almost
puzzle book but he's holding back a
punchline he recounts how in old Japan
women wrote entire books using only the
syllable characters because writing with
the traditional Han characters was seen
as the masculine thing to do but he
knows of another land he's heard exotic
tales of the West where people write out
all of their sounds logically he pauses
he can't quite grasp this himself you
snicker as you think back on how you saw
the alphabet develop with your own eyes
in your journeys you would know so you
sit down and show him how to write every
vowel and consonant with
that couple dozen shapes and you can
write any sound you smile and think so
simple but he lets out an unimpressed
sigh why do all the characters look so
different so haphazard I mean you make
foie and voix by putting your bottom lip
against your top teeth the only
difference is that your throat vibrates
when you say wha he quizzes you why do
you write feh and voix and he goes on
interrogating you what about BA why does
it look that way when it's just taking
the bus sound and saying it through
smacked lips seems you underestimated
the king he doesn't want any old
alphabet he wants a writing system that
shows the various features of sounds
that the sound is made in your throat
against your teeth made with your lips
and so on he puts his brightest scholars
to work giving them the humble name of
the Hall of worthies and go the experts
and out comes another major moments in
the history of writing they develop
Korean Hangul a featural alphabet every
syllable gets separated out into its own
block the syllables consonants and
vowels will be written side by side
within that block each consonant and
vowel letter inside that block will be
shaped according to its features so here
are the consonants that get pronounced
with the lips see the similar lip shape
hears gah
and here is cut again similar sounds
similar shape the featural alphabet was
so simple and straightforward that one
of the king's historians almost dared
people to learn it if you're smart you
can learn it in one morning if you're a
fool it'll take you ten days not
everyone's jumping on the Hangul easy
train community accessible writing
bothers traditionalists who skip out on
the innovation and keep using Chinese
characters fitted to Korean hanja or Han
characters even into the 1900s still for
the rest writing is easier than ever it
has its first rock star it even gets its
own holiday Oh writing you've come a
long long way from pictographs in a cave
you